and going going. Y
money for you. He won. See, gambling
pays off, kids. This is your future.
This is what you do. What an absolute
dirt bag. Shame on you. This man needs
to be boycotted. It needs to be
reported. Yeah. Okay. To the Afghani
officials. I'm telling you. Yeah. This
is disgusting. You are there and you're
saying that gambling will change their
life. Gambling destroys your lives in
the Western world, my friend. Assalamu
alaykum. I really want to thank Walk
forever for partnering with Abdullah in
this absolutely amazing very very
important project of providing
prosthetic limbs to those thousands
who've lost their limbs in Gaza. They
are telling us that this is the best
gift you could have given us. Restoring
the mobility is like restoring their
lives. That's what they're saying. So,
subhan Allah, people have lost both
limbs, people have lost hands and uh
legs. uh some above the knee, some below
the knee. Mashallah, this is just one
example
of Ahmed Ahmed. Mashallah, he's one of
the so many whom we've been able to
assist with your partnership. So, may
Allah reward you and grant you goodness
and may Allah almighty continue to use
all of us to do this good work.
[Music]
Welcome to brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Have you guys ever heard of the
term white man's burden? Now the term
white man's burden originates from a
poem by British writer uh Rodiard
Kipling in in 1898 which urged western
nations particularly the United States
to take on the responsibility of
bringing European law and culture to
colonized regions. So what it is is
there a white man's burden is that our
life and our morals and morality is so
great, so amazing. Let's just take it to
the savages. The ones that they call
savages are 100 times better human
beings than they could ever be. And I'm
not trying to generalize every single
individual in the west. Yes. And that's
what it is. Now we've got a video in
Afghanistan of this blogger, YouTuber,
whatever is for that matter going there
manipulating probably paying these young
children and this elderly man in
Afghanistan um under the Taliban rule
and going there and trying to share his
values with the Afghan people. Let's see
what those values are. I mean, I'm so
intrigued. It must be amazing.
Life-changing. It definitely is,
inshallah. Yeah. So, let's see. And
that's why we um I I agree with a lot of
Islamophobes that come and say, you
know, Islam is against Western values.
I'm not 100% right. Cuz your values are
disgusting. Islam is no way promoting
that kind of stuff. So, here is the
video in let's watch it for oursel and
let's see. The Taliban is going to come
to know about this. And I wonder what
they're going to say. Maybe they might
watch this video. Maybe I I don't know.
Maybe I might have some people out there
who watch my videos. They people watch
my videos in all kinds of places. You
never know. A Taliban member might watch
this video and say, "Oh, hold on a
second." You know, um, why is this man
promoting the stuff in our country?
Let's watch for ourselves. Bin Laden's
house in Tora Bora, Afghanistan, and
we've met the village elders. We've got
the children around here, and we're
going to teach them about CSGO Empire.
CS Empire. That sounds flipping amazing.
It sounds very amazing. I don't going to
teach these kids to have empires, to,
you know, have a halal income, whatever
it is. I don't know. Let's see. So, this
old man over here, he fought the
Americans and the Soviets of 40 years.
He's a strong warrior.
He's a strong warrior. That's what the
Americans used to call the Afghanistan
Afghan, you know, when they were
fighting the Russia and they used to
finance them, etc. Until until they made
up this whole thing about 9/11, etc.,
which the whole world has woken up to
now, how those buildings fell, etc. Call
it conspiracy, whatever you like. The
whole world knows who is really behind
those in the 9/11 and the the laughing
Zionist, you know, and how they had p
knowledge of that. But anyways, let's
carry on. There was the strong now. It's
back to Yeah. But because the terrorist
knows Yeah. Let's go. And he took a
gamble. But the real gamble that pays
off, guys, is gambling. Oh. Oh. Okay.
Interesting. He's being smart. You know,
he took a big gamble. But the real
gamble is what? I mean, what's he going
to talk about? Is he going to talk about
investment? He's going to talk about how
to, you know, change their lives for the
better. Is he there to help them? I
mean, he looks like a lovely white man
that, you know, I wonder what he has to
offer Afghanistan. Here we go. What we
going to do? We're going to play this
and terrorist. Allah Abbar. Allahbar.
Hey, I got to play something that was so
convincing. This is what we're going to
play. Ya Allah, spin it, habibi. Woo!
Put some animations. Dollars falling
out. Tell the kids what told the kids.
You listen when I spin this I this. And
then you going to say we they probably
pay them. Yeah. Probably $1, etc. Yeah.
Okay. As you can see, like literally
using them. Okay. Manipulating them.
Okay. Let's let's carry on. Let's see
how much we can win. Let's see. Let's
see. I'm feeling lucky, guys. Let's do
it one more time. Yeah. I'll have it one
more time. This is not scripted, by the
way. This is purely chance. Let's see.
Are they going to win or lose this time?
I mean, they might lose. Let's see. And
going
[Applause]
for you. He won. See, gambling pays off,
kids. This is your future. This is what
you do. And I want a gift. What an
absolute dirt bag. What an absolute dirt
bag. And this man, I don't even know his
name. I I don't even remember his
flipping name. Um, Subhan Allah. I will
try to put it in the screenshot here.
This dirtback, he's also Christian,
Catholic. Gambling is not allowed in
Christianity. He's going to Afghanistan.
They have been through so much turmoil.
They have been killed. Half a million
people were killed, innocent people by
the white man who tried to come and save
them. You know, Bush and this that may
Allah destroy them and this and the
hereafter and Tony Blair. And subhan
Allah, he's going there and he's saying
gambling will change your life. Brothers
and sisters, let me show you a little
clip of a man in the United Kingdom. He
was addicted to gambling. He was about
to kill himself. I know person and
family members who rob their own
mothers, rob their own family members
for gambling. Here's a little clip
before actually we'll come to the clip
after this. Yeah, he's going there and
he's promoting gambling, giving money to
brainwash these kids to thinking that is
right. Do you know how gambling destroys
lives? Brothers and sisters, let's look
at some statistics. Okay, let's look at
some statistics. Gambling addiction,
also known as a problem of gambling or
gambling disorder. It's a disorder. How
the hell can it be the sword if you
don't ever play it? Flipping. Anyways,
so uh is a significant global issue with
prevalence rates varying across
different regions and demographics.
Estimates suggest that 1.2% of the
world's adult population experiences
some for form of gambling disorder.
That's nearly 100 million people and
imagine how many people um indirectly is
affected by that. Okay. Um however, the
number can range from 1.2% to 6%
depending on the study and region.
Furthermore, around 5.5% of women and
11% of men globally experience some
level of harm from gambling. Subhan
Allah. Yeah. And this is what he's
promoting. Okay, let's carry on. Right
now, this merch from CSGO Empire, which
you can wear. I think this is good for
him. Very good. Wow. Beautiful.
Wow. He looks so good. So, these people
make less than $1 a day, but through
CSGO Empire, we have made up to $5 right
now in one quick easy spin.
Unbelievable. Unbelievable. What? how
evil you have to be that see these
people and what they've been through,
what they've gone through, how little
they make, how innocent they are, and
take them for a ride like this. Shame on
you. This man needs to be boycotted
needs to be reported. Yeah. Okay. To the
Afghani officials, I'm telling you.
Yeah. This is disgusting. You are there
and you're saying that gambling will
change their life. Gambling destroys
your lives in the Western world, my
friend. They're paying you. You only
care about yourself because the money
that you're making, you don't care about
them. They've paid you a certain amount.
So, you're going there and thinking,
"Yeah, I'm going to promote this one."
It makes me sick. It genuinely makes me
sick. Let's carry on. CSGO's Empire's
legal team keeps talking about women's
rights in Afghanistan. So, I've got a
woman here who's going to be empowered
by gambling. Lady, please, can you press
this? Oh. Oh, I think we're going. Hey,
we
he throws money in there. Says that the
legal team, they are fighting for
women's rights. Is it? Which one of
rights are you talking about, my friend?
Yes. Look how he's throwing money in. If
I was there, I think if I was that
person, I would physically beat this guy
up. I will physically beat him up with a
stick, bro. What a disgusting viral man.
Let's talk about the rights that he is
talking about. Yeah, let's let's talk
about that in one second. Okay, let's
talk about the woman's right. This is
some of the women's right. But research
finds that 97% of women in the UK have
been sexually harassed. Okay. An
investigation by UN Woman UK found that
97% of women aged 18 to 24. Nearly every
single woman have been sexually um
harassed has been harassed. Yeah. With a
further 96% not reporting those
situations because of the belief that it
would not change anything. That is exact
the the point, brothers and sisters.
Okay. For example, another one from uh
this is the National Center for Domestic
Violence, a community invest. There we
go. Okay. So, let's go for it. says one
in five adults experienced domestic
abuse during their lifetimes equating to
one in four women this woman's right and
one one in six seven for men last year
2.5 million adults were victims 1.7
million women etc okay so and and the
list the list goes on the point is what
guys yeah he's talking about women's
rights women have been sexually abused
they get sexually abused they are
nothing but sexual objects they are
being marketed yes why basically
empowering you know mah the gambling
place not only they rob you they're
trying to empower the Afghani woman the
biggest the woman that who've been
oppressed the most are the western
women. Yes, they have to dress up a
certain way, get their botox done, get
their backside done, get step breast
done, have the beauty industry standards
there. Um and and as you guys know, I
always promote the book beauty sick a
sickness starving their self going and
sleeping around with men for validation.
The the the lowest like they have
degraded women to such a low level,
lower than a woman, a lower than a a
animal. And not only that, subhan Allah,
they have made them toilet. Why do we go
toilet guys? We go toilet to do number
one and number two to relieve ourel.
These men are relieving theirelves in
these women by not giving them any
rights, sexually just using them and
chucking them away. They are like
walking toilets. That's why so many
people are coming to Islam. Let's watch
this last bit in of this shameless man
um taking advantage of these innocent
people. CSGO.
We love CSGO Empire, guys. Please follow
him on X and God bless CSGO Empire.
Casinos are charities, guys. They give
so much money and they make so little
and they're changing lives around here.
Thank you, Monarch. I mean, I don't know
if this guy's being sarcastic. I'll be
honest at one. I'm just thinking, is
this a joke? Is this some kind of I
don't know what is the honor? What's I
have no idea what it is. It might be
that this not the case. Yeah. But it
still doesn't take from the point
because this what sadly this is what
these powers do sadly. Yeah. So he's
gone there manipulating the situation,
taking advantage of them, talking about
women's rights, got some people there,
some kids there, promoting his way of
life that is absolutely vile. And so
many of them are suffering here.
Gambling addiction, murder, theft,
depression, anxiety, unhappiness,
unrest, uh, and what's it called? And
depressing, uh, uh, um, prescriptions
going sky sky high, subhan Allah, going
throughout the through the roof. Why?
Because people are unhappy. and he's
trying to go and give to these innocent
people who are happy with little things.
Subhan Allah. I hope the Afghan
authorities catch this man and kick him
out the country. It's as simple as that.
I hope they catch him and kick him out
the country. This is disgusting. That's
the reason why Islam is the best
solution to world to the whole entire
world brothers and sisters because it
protects your mind, your soul, your
body, the rights of others. It doesn't
come and say gamble. You know gamble
destroys people's lives. This is a video
of a young man. You can even watch it on
YouTube little clip where he was going
to end his life throwing himself in
front of a train because he lost so much
to gambling. It destroys lives and Islam
is there to preserve life. Brothers and
sisters, that's what I'm going to say.
Inshallah. May Allah bless and preserve
you guys inshallah.